do you have advice
for young people speaking of being
excited about
and hopeful about the future world do
you have uh advice for young people
today
in computer science world and software
engineering world and crypto world but
maybe in any world whatsoever um
for life how to pick a career or how to
live life in general
i think the thing that that that young
people should do
is is not any one specific thing for any
any one specific young
person i think what they should do is
what they
won't be able to do in the later stages
of their life
yeah and the way in my opinion from a
framework point of view to think about
that
is that the amount of obligations
and the amount of time that a person has
seems to just diminish over time right
so the amount of free time they have
right
so you start your job you get a bunch of
responsibilities some something with
your partner's spouse
more responsibilities kids probably even
more responsibilities
and soon enough the time that you have
to educate yourself to travel
to you know experience the world however
create whatever creative endeavor you're
interested in um
slowly but surely disappears i think
this is something that you know young
people don't fully
realize they they assume that the world
as it is now
and the amount of free time that they
have
to travel to educate themselves to make
new friends
to do all these things will somehow
maybe diminish by ten percent
it won't diminish by ten percent it'll
diminish by ninety percent
yeah and the ten percent that you have
you'll be resting
to get back to work and get things done
so yeah what i think young people should
do and this is why it's very different
for each of them right
i can't tell young people hey you should
study philosophy
travel and start your own enterprise to
achieve something worthwhile in the
world right that might be
something that's good for me with my
values and my um
kind of world view but for other people
might be something else
i i think the way that they should
conceptualize it
is imagine if
over the next um 10 12 years
the amount of choice that you had about
what you could do
was cut down by 90 percent
what would you and this is you know
copying from this kind of just
jeff bezos regret minimization framework
in that framework it's like what would i
regret not doing at 80
and that's kind of meant to create this
long-term view
and make these decisions now that'll get
you to
a long-term future that you can look
back on and be proud of your life right
what i think young people should do is
they is they they should say to
themselves look
if i never get the chance to travel for
as long as i live
assuming that after 25 after 27 after 29
that's the case
how will i feel about that if i never
get to start a company
after 25 after i get married after i
have kids
how will i feel about that and whatever
they feel the worst about
is what they should do whatever they
feel like when they say to themselves
you know if i don't travel now i will
never travel
and they feel horrible about that they
just have an overwhelming
fear and disgust at themselves
in that type of state at 25
27 29 that's what they should do
and they shouldn't listen to anybody
else um
i i i let me put it through this way
if you're really smart you're gonna make
it anyway
there's a lot of people putting a lot of
pressure on you because they're afraid
whether you're gonna make it if you're
really smart you're going to make it
anyway
if you're not really smart you're
screwed anyway
so either way just relax with it and
use your time well to do the the the
things you would
most regret not doing that's really
fascinating
i wouldn't i wouldn't say relax i would
say very much cherish
the free time yeah the discretionary
time that you have
from the age of 18 to maybe 25.
yeah because at 25 everyone's going to
start looking at each other
and asking what have what have i
achieved like my friends have achieved i
haven't achieved
and then by the time you get to 30
you're going to look at each other again
and go
well my friends have a family or a
company
or a phd or whatever what do i have
and the pressure will just increase and
it'll increase so much
that even if you want to go and do the
fun thing
it will not be fun because the pressure
yeah
of comparing yourself to your friends at
25 or your peers at
30 will be so great that you will
no longer it will no longer be normal
for you to be in a hostel at 30
you know kind of like living it up right
if if and and and this is why i also
can't tell you specifically what it is
for me
it was getting an education in
philosophy that was rigorous and
in-depth
it was traveling and it was starting an
enterprise that i thought were that was
worthwhile that i directed that i could
make into something great that's what it
was for me
for other people it might be something
with a band it might be something with
painting
it might be an education you you by the
way should
also should not assume that your ability
to get an education
will improve all of those
responsibilities
will take away your ability to get an
education
so if you value having an education if
you value being
a deeply educated well-rounded person
with a wide array of knowledge on a wide
array of topics
capitalism will force you to specialize
that's what it's good at
it's going to take you it's going to
fashion you into a very specific tool
for a very most people into a very
specific set of tasks
if you want to have an education in
something get it now
if you want to travel somewhere travel
there now if you want to you know do
some kind of creative endeavor that you
doubt whether you'll have time for in
the future do it now
you won't have time for it in the future
you won't have time
to read philosophy books all day
unfortunately you won't have time
to fly to you know italy and
kind of hang out with people if you're
serious about your life
you're going to get more
responsibilities you're going to get
more stuff to do
and so my advice to you is do not piss
away
this rare unique discretionary time
and if your friends are get new friends
get smarter friends get people who are
using the limited time they have better
yeah um that's my advice so it's just a
quick
comment it's brilliant you know to
reframe high school and
undergraduate college education
sometimes people
want to quickly get it over with but
one thing i remember thinking
and it's very true about high school is
one of the only times in
in your life you'll get a chance to
truly get a broad education
you don't often think of it that way but
it's a chance to really
enjoy learning things that are outside
of the specialty that you'll eventually
end up with and that's how college
education is
and a more fun side i played music
i i did martial arts and we offline
mentioned played video games
i find it fascinating and brilliant what
you said
which is the world will will not give
you a chance to truly
enjoy many of these things and truly get
value from many of those things
uh once you get older i find it
exceptionally difficult to enjoy video
games now
there's so much stuff to do so
responsibility
and i at the time when i played elder
scrolls
and bulger's gate and diablo 2 and
at the time i thought maybe that was a
waste of time
but now looking back i realize
because i always thought you know let me
get the career first and then i'll have
a chance to play video games that's the
way i was thinking
you know it was a waste of time because
i should really
progress on the career and then i'll
have time to play video games no the
reality is
that was really fulfilling those are
some of the happiest
travel experiences of my life is me
traveling to those
virtual worlds and spending time in them
and it was really fulfilling and they
stay with me for the rest of my life
and i get to experience echoes of that
when i play video games these days for
an hour here an hour there
like one hour a month or something like
that but
even those experiences as silly as they
are they seem like a waste of time at
the time
enjoying them fully unapologetically
and you know in a framework exactly as
you said would i regret
being the kind of person who've never
played those video games
and i can for myself honestly say that
yes
look when i'm on my deathbed
i'm i'm glad at boulder's gate yeah we
built
ballers gate 2 and and all those uh
arena daggerfall morrowind
and all the elder scrolls games and
um yeah
the things that don't necessarily fit
into this kind of storyline of what a
career is supposed to be
travel and all those experiences that
you might i think i just like to say one
one one final quick thing on on this um
i think this extends to really hard
things as well it extends to the things
you want to do
but one of the best pieces of advice one
of my mentors um
gave me early on in in my career at
around this time
is that it will actually become harder
to start a company
as you get older yes once again because
you have more responsibilities you're
responsible
to your partner for some kind of income
to create a life together once you have
kids you're responsible for an even
greater income
to create a life for kids and startups
do not
generate income right they take many
many years before anything happens
people are getting evicted people are
eating ramen noodles that is a thing
that happens
that that that will happen so i'm not
saying that you should
do the fun things or the enjoyable
things i'm saying
the things that you would regret not
doing
that you can uniquely do in the time
span from 18
to 25 which one of which
is if you plan to have a family and
start a family when you're 25
you should start a company now you
should not wait until a bunch of people
depend on you for income to eat
to start a company the amount of
pressure that will be on you at that
point
will be monumental you should start a
company when nobody depends on you
and you can sleep on the floor eating
ramen noodles
and still have a great time and show up
with a lot of enthusiasm
and be excited so um i i just mean
whatever you want
to really devote yourself to and and and
really do
don't put it off don't go to consulting
or banking or any
other industry and say i'm going to do
this for three years and i'll get
experience
the only way you get experience is by
doing something you go
you do it you fail you do it again and
again and again and again and again
and then you have experience and then
you can do it right that's the only way
experience happens there is no other way
short of mentorship if you're lucky to
get mentorship 99 of people don't get
mentorship
and even though we're talking about
young people i feel like you're speaking
to me as somebody who's
who spent the last two weeks sleeping on
the floor because there's no mattress
and somebody who is single and somebody
who's thinking about it doing a startup
i felt like you're speaking to me as a
as a fellow young person
let me ask you about this whole
life of ours to zoom out on the big
philosophical question the ridiculous
question
what do you think is the meaning of it
all
do you think about this kind of stuff as
you're creating all the technology
uh as you're thinking about this future
you ever zoom out and think like why
why why are you sergey striving why are
we
the human species striving for the stars
so i think it comes down to um you know
whether
people want to live in society so if
if people decide to be part of society
they have a certain um
set of conditions that they decide to
take part in
right so i i think what this what this
comes down to
is a lot of really involved
conversations
but if we assume people have free will
and choice we just kind of make that
blanket assumption
then the question starts to become well
what choices do we make
and how do we live with those choices
and
i think probably the most fundamental
choice is whether we
exist in a society or we choose to leave
society
and there are people that do this there
are people that go live in the woods
there are people that immigrate to other
societies
and they make a choice right and as they
enter those other societies or they
choose to leave
leave society and go live in the woods
they
adopt a certain set of values right they
adopt values that the society prescribes
they compromise their own values they
define their own values and they create
a set of values for themselves
right i think
at the end of the day if you're going to
choose to live in society
in addition to all the minimums of you
know not throwing garbage on the floor
and
you know doing doing nice things for
people that need help and
and doing any number of things to just
be a normal human being within society
you you have to ask yourself what am i
doing as part of society
right you can always say hey i'm going
to leave society i'm going to live in
the woods
i did that right i went and i lived in
the woods and i gave it a shot
realized a ton of stuff huge amount of
clarity from that but
when you decide to live in society you
you take on
um first of all certain minimal
agreements
you you mold your values a little bit to
that society that's another choice that
people
inherently make and then there's
uh a question of well what am i doing
here right what am i doing
in society right so when people say the
meaning of life
i don't know what the meaning of life is
the meaning of life in society
right what what's the meaning of life
for the choice that you've made within
society right because that's
maybe the first fundamental choice you
made you made a choice and you continue
to make a choice
to be part of society and a specific
society
right so you've made this choice you're
part of a society
and now you kind of have
a life and you have people around you
and then the question is in my in my
opinion the question is what is the body
of work
that you want to make right
i think personally that life is kind of
so short
and the ability to get enough resources
for yourself in
at least the developed markets where
we're like lucky to be in
is so relatively abundant that
we you and me have the luxury you know
by your pursuit of a phd
you know you've had this luxury i've had
this luxury um
through the work that i've been doing to
pursue
something that makes society better
so this is kind of the um
question i would say the question is am
i going to live in society yes or no yes
okay most people choose yes
i understand why to a degree i
understand why some people choose now
and then um what is the but i'm going to
be in society i'm going to
if you choose to be in society you're
just choosing to abide by the rules
you're choosing to just do the minimum
right that's what being part of society
means
people that choose to be part of society
but don't want to do this it's very
confusing
they should just leave they should just
go look i don't like this deal
i'm going to go somewhere else i'm gonna
live in tibet i'm gonna live in the
woods
i'm gonna live wherever where the rules
are to my liking right
um you you've chosen to be in society
next question kind of final question is
what is the body of work
that i'm going to be involved in because
in looking at that jeff bezos kind of
regret minimization framework thing
i think that's what a lot of it really
comes down to is you kind of
the framework is at eight years old you
look back over your life what would you
regret not doing
what would you regret not not pursuing
i think there there are a number of
things on a personal level each person
has
but i think at least for me and
and probably for many of the other
people i know there's a question of
what is the body of work that i was
involved in
what did i do what what happened right
what was i involved in
and in my opinion you you should have a
good answer to that
and you mentioned the body work in
relation to
whether it helped make a better world
and
the fundamental question there is what
does better mean
so it's our striving to understand what
is better
what kind of world would we love to
exist
after we're gone and i think that's
another
thing almost unanswerable question but
it's one we can strive
towards is what is what is a better
world
right i i think that's all that's that's
once again a very that's a very personal
question i'm not sure if there's an
objective moral truth
that's going to suddenly give us all an
answer i think it's actually quite uh
fascinating to me when people feel they
have this objective moral truth they're
so sure in their opinions you know
this is what we do we should go you know
hurt them or help them or
kill them or or rescue them or whatever
right there's this there's all these
kind of
very situational specific kind of like
this is the right thing to do the
objective moral truth told me
that this is it but maybe there's a
definitive truth
that we can uh arrive towards uh sort of
a consensus
of what that is within the little local
pocket
of society that you're in yeah that's
the point that that's what happens
people just then mislabel it and they go
like objective moral truth
yeah this is this is not my this is not
our idea yeah you know this is coming up
from on high here this is
this is the this is the the objective
moral truth that
you know i i think exists in some
metaphysical form
somewhere and then you build a building
with marble and it's big and
usually what happens and then you
convince yourself that that building
represents i think those people actually
under the people who build those
buildings under
probably understand that there is no
metaphysical object they're just like
we're all just coming to consensus i'm
going to build the biggest building and
you're like me and that's what we're
going to do right like
they just they just look at it that way
probably i
i i think i think what ends up happening
with with all these values is yeah
people should determine that for
themselves i
i agree that there's a second order
question here of what is the best the
the best body of work to work on um
personally i think that's probably a mix
of
what could you realistically achieve you
know
is that going to have an impact on
society that you feel good about yeah
right so these these are probably the
two aspects of this question
and is this going to have a good impact
on society that you feel good about
obviously very subjective right some
people save animals some people say
forests
um we and and i are creating this uh
system of economic fairness and
transparency
i feel that i'm in a good position to
enable that
i feel that i have a good chance of
succeeding at that and i think that the
impact will be
quite um quite meaningful for a large
number of people
and so i'm completely happy to look back
once i'm 80 and see a body of work that
achieved that
and be very proud of that right because
i think that's what i'll be doing
when i'm looking back so well i agree
with you the the scale of impact
as a smart hybrid smart contracts this
whole idea that you're working on
has the potential to transform the world
for the better
at a scale that
that i can't even imagine so speaking of
which
means even more that you would waste so
many hours of that exciting life with me
thank you so much for talking today
sergey this is a really fascinating
conversation
a really fascinating space and i can't
wait to learn more so thank you so much
for talking today
thank you for having me it's been an
absolute pleasure
you